hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
Rishi sunat confirms he is going to
cop27 reversing an earlier decision to
stay away
we'll be taking a look at what lies
ahead for the prime minister at the
climate conference in Egypt and who will
be attending and who won't
also ahead lead by example a new report
finds the government is failing on its
own pledge to reach Net Zero by 2050 and
and it's up to us to find a solution
protecting our planet for the future
research by Sky Kids reveals half of all
children are frightened when they hear
news about climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis but we start the show
today with a U-turn by the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak who has confirmed
he will be attending the cop 27 Summit
in Egypt Mr sunac initially said he
wasn't going to head to the conference
in Sharm El Sheikh due to other pressing
domestic commitments and this is what he
tweeted earlier today
there is no long-term Prosperity without
action on climate change and there is no
energy security without investing in
Renewables and this is why I'll attend
cop 27 next week to deliver on glagut
glasgow's Legacy of building a secure
and sustainable future
well the decision came less than 24
hours after Boris Johnson the former
prime minister confirmed to Sky News in
an exclusive interview that he will be
attending the summit
are you going to go to cop 27
yes as it happens but um that's uh
that's not relevant to Ukraine and final
question I mean do you still Harbor
Homes I was invited by his invited by
the by the Egyptian stun
and you presumably think the Prime
Minister should go I think the the
premise is doing uh as as he's pointed
out he's got a massive amount to do
we've got to sort out uh a huge
agenda and that's what he's getting on
with
um I haven't had a particular I was at
the Glasgow cop although it's become I'm
fashionable to talk about it was a
fantastic Global success we did a huge
amount of good for the planet I want to
talk a little bit about uh how uh I see
things and how we see things in the UK
well let's talk to our climate change
and energy correspondent Hannah Thomas
Peter thanks for joining us um what do
you think this say says about sunax
commitment to The Climate crisis then
Hannah
well it gives the appearance of a leader
who was happy to let climate change slip
down the agenda a little bit but then
changed his mind when it became
politically painful
I think his supporters of course would
say that that's a very uncharitable
assessment and the Mr sunak is deeply
committed to Net Zero committed in
particular to accelerating investment in
cheap clean power sources like offshore
wind and committed to the opportunity
that a green economy would bring but
make no mistake about it you know Rishi
sunak even thinking about not turning up
to cop27 when the UK was the host of
cop26 as Boris Johnson was just saying
there to Great Fanfare that has put a
real dent in the UK's reputation as a
global climate leader and Hannah what
else is going on at Carl but in
particular what do you think Mr sunac
will face when he does arrive there
well there's an eye-wateringly long list
of problems to tackle Mr sunac will join
America's Joe Biden Francis Emmanuel
macron a Scottish first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon and others as they
look really at one overarching problem
which is strengthening the resolve of
the International Community to keep 1.5
degrees Celsius of warming Within Reach
if possible as various issues like War
political instability inflation and
energy crisis threatened to pull the
planet even further off track than it
already is and the other thing that's
threatening to overshadow the entire
Summit is this growing row over payments
compensation from Rich Nations who
became wealthy as a result of burning
fossil fuels finding the cash to to pay
poorer Nations for the damage already
inflicted as a result of climate change
it's a perennial problem at cops this
disparity between Rich Nations and poor
Nations but as climate disasters fold
across the planet as we see Pakistan
underwater we see heat waves in Europe
and wildfires in California these issues
are being thrown into sharp relief and
there is anger and frustration that more
isn't being done by the wealthiest
Nations on the planet
okay Hannah thank you very much for that
update well let's take a close look for
you at what we can expect because cop
sees world leaders isn't it come
together to discuss and agree how to
jointly address climate change and its
impacts now the Fortnight of
negotiations kick off with a world
leaders Summit on the 7th and 8th of
November where high level talks between
heads of states will take place and
after this officials will tackle some of
the biggest issues surrounding the
climate each day on the 9th of November
for example Finance day will see
delegates discuss how to use economies
to fund climate Solutions around the
world or the 10th of November is
scheduled to be both science day and
youth in future Generations day
Representatives will discuss how
technology and younger people could make
a difference and towards the end
Solutions day government officials
business representatives and innovators
will come together and share their ideas
on how to tackle the climate crisis over
90 heads of state have confirmed their
attendance next week including U.S
President Joe Biden Scotland's first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon and French
president Emmanuel macron meanwhile
Chinese president Xi Jinping and Russian
President Vladimir Putin are not
expected to attend also missing out on
the events will be King Charles III
despite his long-held concerns about
climate
or companies have long been encouraged
to set Net Zero Targets in the UK but a
new report has found the government
itself is failing to lead by example on
cutting greenhouse gas emissions there's
a legal binding Target isn't there to
reach Net Zero by 2050 and the report by
The public's account committee describe
a poor quality of emissions meaning
measuring and Reporting across central
governments so how are others supposed
to well clean up their acts well joining
me now is Sarah only a lead member of
this report by the Public Accounts
committee hello Sarah thanks so much for
joining us
um what are your thoughts overall on
this report it's not glowing
no that's right I mean what we found in
our inquiry was that there's a quite a
lot of confusion about what the targets
are how they're set how to that how data
should be collected how it's reported
and what we also found was a real
failing to follow up where departments
were uh failing to meet those targets
there was really no uh that there was no
enforcement there was no comeback there
was no plan to help them no resources
allocated
um so what we found was a real mishmash
uh across central government when it
came to uh you know setting and
achieving targets for the greenhouse gas
emissions reduction
um and that's that's really adding up to
quite a lot of uh we think missed
opportunities to really make a
difference
so what do you think needs to happen
next because the government they've made
this legally binding commitment to reach
Net Zero by 2050 and based on this
report do you think that's achievable
um we're something that's achievable but
what really needs to happen is a real
focus on uh on on what what's going to
be required to get there we need a plan
we need a strategy and we need uh
certainly across central government when
it comes to uh to combat in greenhouse
gas emissions there needs to be a much
more joined up uh sort of centralized
way of setting targets for each
department measuring
um and you know a couple of using the
data that's collected to drive decision
making to to share this practice and
really to make better decisions about
how to allocate resources in order to
help those departments that are not
meeting their targets okay so only a big
job ahead there that's the a lead member
of the report from the Public Accounts
committee thanks for joining us
now in other climate news temperatures
in Europe have been increased more than
twice the global average over the past
30 years now the highest of any
continents in the world actually a new
European union state of climate reports
said Europe presents a live picture of a
warming world and it warns that should
warning continue heat waves wildfires
floods and other climate change impacts
will affect society
a new poll suggests the majority of
people think the government is doing too
little on climate change the survey for
Aid agency carford ahead of cop 27 also
found that almost half of those quiz I
didn't think the government was
committed to its climate goals and the
government has a legal Target as we are
saying there to cut emissions to Net
Zero overall by 2050 and they hosted
last year's cop 26 climate Summits in
Glasgow
Now new research shows rhino horns have
steadily shrunk over the last 100 years
and scientists believe it may be due to
hunting long-horned rhinos have been
poached for years and scientists believe
those with smaller horns are more likely
to survive and then pass their genes
down to Future Generations the Rhino
remains an endangered species
now a survey by Sky Kids has revealed
that half of children are frightened by
climate change with the majority wanting
schools to teach more on the subjects of
brand new study asked 2 000 children
aged between 7 and 14 about their views
on climate change
well it revealed that nearly half of
children claim that climate change is
the biggest issue facing the planet
right now and only 10 of children think
the government is doing enough to tackle
climate change but it's not all negative
as 63 of children think it's not too
late to save the planets well our
special Program for Young People FYI
will be looking at all of this in detail
as well as a special film here on Sky
News this weekend cop 27 six ways to
save our planet
we're all so lucky that this is our home
a place where creatures are free to roam
but the climate is changing because of
pollution and it's up to us to find a
solution
United has won our ideas to share
you can help too because we all care
[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome FYI presenter at
Braden bent into the studio thanks so
much for joining us this afternoon we
see there from the figures that lots of
children are suffering from climate
anxiety tell us a little bit about what
you found in particular yes so fyi's
major survey question 2007 to 14 year
olds across the UK and our findings were
really interesting actually because as
you mentioned there 43 of us think that
climate change is the biggest issue
facing our planet right now but there is
a bit of positive news in there because
63 of us said that it's not too late to
save the planet now 81 of us also want
to be taught more about the climate
crisis in school and I think that shows
that we're keen we want to learn more
and also we've got our own ideas about
you know what can be done I know and
that leads me on to my second question
actually because there will be lots of
young children watching this perhaps
know you and follow you and they'll be
wondering you know what can I do to make
a difference and also ease away a bit of
anxiety too yes so as well as FYI survey
there's a new Sky Kid scan news
documentary coming out this weekend
called cop27 six ways to save our planet
and that's a brilliant watch because
there's loads of tips on what we can do
all do to help and also you know there's
loads of really inspiring stories in
there and I think that's really
important because anybody can watch it
and gather stuff from it and also our
survey found out that 89 of us are
trying to recycle and go cleaner with
our rubbish 82 percent of us are turning
off the lights to save electricity 62
percent of us cycle or water score and
27 of us are eating less meat than we
used to and that just shows that
although we're limited to what we can do
we are trying our best yeah and there's
the small things that you can do in your
everyday life that can make a difference
great and thank you so much thanks for
having me for joining us